We're going to talk about magic squares of
squares. So first thing we're going to do is
uh talk about what a magic square is. We're going
to start with a 3x3 grid; we're going
to have 8, 1, 6, 3, 5 and a 7 and 4, 9, 2. So
this is a 3x3 array of numbers and
what's incredible here is that if you add the
numbers down the columns - so like 8 plus 3
plus 4 - you're gonna get 15. You're gonna
get 15 no matter what column you add down. Or if
you look at the rows and if you add those up then
you also get 15, so all the rows add up to 15 and
also the two diagonals. So the principal diagonal,
- so this is 5 plus 2 is 7, plus 8
is 15 - and then if you look at the other
diagonal so 4 plus 6 is 10 plus 5 is 15. So
everything adds up to 15; so columns, rows and
the two diagonals add up to 15. That's a perfect,
pure magic square. In fact this is the earliest of
you know up to some sort of rearrangement of the
of the numbers; it's uh it's the earliest known uh
recorded magic square. It's usually called the the
Lo Shu. There's records of it from about 2200 BC.
The Chinese tradition has it that the Emperor Yu
uh saw this magic square on the back of a turtle,
it's a sort of beautiful story.
- (Brady: I know there are
lots of other magic squares, we're going to talk)
(about them shortly; is a magic square still
a magic square if any number is repeated? Or is)
(that kind of imperfect?)
- I- so I would argue that
those are imperfect magic squares. And and in
fact that's that's kind of what makes it hard
I think to to find magic squares. If you allow
repetitions, you know you you can really find magic
squares quite easily right? I could just repeat
all the numbers here, right, just take your
favorite number, -19, I'd think it would
be 9 but 9 is not prime so it's 19. So if I
put 19 everywhere in these nine entries I'll just
get a magic square that way but it feels like
it's not it's not a real magic square. It feels
like a fake magic square. So what I want to do is
look at 3x3 magic squares but I want to
impose one more condition, which is that I want the
entries themselves to be the squares of numbers.
So I'm going to draw for you an example of this
and it'll be a bit of a cheat; people who've been
seeing Numberphile videos for a while are going to
recognize this. So this is 29 squared, 1 squared, 47
squared, 41 squared, 37 squared, 1 squared, 23 squared,
41 squared, and 29 squared. And this is a very famous
magic square and it was made famous by Numberphile; so this is the the Parker Square.
- So I'm not
calling it The Parker Square.
- (Matt, you know whatthis video is called?)
- I'm calling it- oh for cryingout loud...
(This was famously Matt's attempt at allsquares?)
- That's right, that's right. It's a very good
attempt. I think this this is a very reasonable uh
attempt; in fact it it complies with almost all the
requirements of of a of a magic square of squares,
right? So every single entry is a square number,
right, uh and it's it's true that if you add up
all the rows and all the columns and if you add
up the two diagonals it all adds up to the same
number so it satisfies the main requirements for
being a magic square.
- (Doesn't- doesn't oneof the diagonals fail?)
- Wait sorry can we checkthat?
This diagonal here works; this diagonal heredoesn't work.
- One of the diagonals does not and so
in in that sense it's not quite a magic square of
squares, it's what people tend to call a semi-magic
square. And there's some repetitions of the
entries; so for example you see the two 1s
here, you see a couple of 29s, a couple of 41s; and
so it sort of feels like it's it's cheating just
a little bit. But it's a really good attempt okay,
so so you know it's it's a good starting point.
You know when you- sometimes in math when you can't
solve a really difficult problem you try to solve
a simpler problem, you know, and and making some of
these- allowing some of these entries to be uh the
same as a way of trying to simplify the problem
that- in a way that might some interesting
mathematics as well.
- (Okay Parker Square, good attempt.)
- Yes. Okay so there are there are
a couple of other uh squares that I want to show
you because- so so as we saw in the Parker Square
there's just a couple of things that aren't quite
right, and there are some really famous ones, these
are sort of from the late 90s. So one of them is
called the Bremner Square, okay this is a big one.
Okay so this is another attempt at a magic square
of squares and it's it's very good in sort of a
different way from the Parker Square. This time
you'll notice almost immediately that there's two
entries that are not squares; that's where thisfails-
- (That feels like an even more fundamental)
(failure to me. Are they close to being squares?)
- Ah I- not really I don't think. It is a little bit
sad that they're not they're not really squares.
But you know what does- what is true here though is
that the columns and the rows and both diagonals
add up to the same thing. So somehow we managed
to at least preserve that property but then we
broke the squares. We do have distinct entries; so
you know you're sort of- you feel like you're
making progress. I mean it'd be you know cool
to have one that had like eight squares, you
know, and maybe only one that's not a square.
I don't know of one and I'm not sure if one has
been found yet. There's another square consisting
of square entries which is almost a magic
square, it's a semi magic square, it's by Sallows.
And in a sense it's sort of a an improvement
on the Parker Square in that all the entries
are distinct; however just like with the Parker
Square, one of the diagonals doesn't add up to
the same number that all the others add up to.
- (Thatfeels like one of the best attempts so far doesn'tit?)
That's right yes. In fact it's it's really
nice that if you just remove one of the conditions
then you really can find them. It's it's a it's
a very difficult problem precisely because of
how all of the conditions come together.
- (Of coursethis is a fundamental question here - does one exist?)
(Has anyone ever found a magic square of squares?)
- Asfar as I know no. It's it's really sad and in fact
what I want to do today is try to convince you
that there probably isn't one, okay? So I know
that's sort of a sad thing to say; uh I would
love for there to be a magic square of squares,
um but but I think sort of of geometry is giving
us a bunch of indications that this just might not
be the case. And so in fact what geometry suggests
is that if there is a magic square of squares it's
going to be really really difficult to find and it's
sort of be beyond what we can do by just sort of
like trying small things.
- (This doesn't look likegeometry to me)
- Right! Right! Oh my God yes, thank
you for that question yeah. Let me try to show you
where the geometry at least starts coming up, let's
do it. So we're trying to find nine numbers, each
of them a square and so I need to give them names.
I'll call them X1 squared and X2 squared and X3
squared and so on. What we're hoping for is nine
distinct positive integers, X1 through X9, um that I
can put into uh one of these 3x3 grids
in such a way that the the rows, the columns, and
the two diagonals add up to the same number. And
so I can actually write out what those conditions
are in terms of just algebra right?
- (Like a jig-)
(monster equation like?)
- Yeah it's going to be a set
of monster equations in fact. So let me show you; so
for example I need to know that the first row is
equal to the sum of the elements of the first row
is equal to the sum of the elements in the second
row so I can just write out this monster equation.
Okay? I also need the same two sums to equal the
sum of the third row; so I can write another equal
sign here. This all has to be the same, okay. I also
need to know that this sum is the same as the sum
of the two diagonals, so let me do those next. So
there's X1 squared plus X5 squared plus X9 squared.
And then the other diagonal, so it'll be
X3 squared plus X5 squared plus X7 squared.
This is a bit messy but we still have to do the
columns; so the first column will be X1 squared
plus X4 squared plus X7 squared, okay, and
then I'll do the second column: X2 squared
plus X5 squared plus X8 squared. Okay, and I'm still
missing the third column, okay. But here's something-
this is a really important observation: so once
I know that all three rows add up to the same
number and the first two columns add up to the
same number, that forces the last column to add
up to the same number as as all the previous uh
rows and columns. And so this last thing is not a
condition that we need to sort of set out because
it's already implied by all the other ones that
we have imposed. So this is sort of an important
thing because it cuts down on the number of equal
signs that I've written, okay? So there's only
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 equal signs. I don't need
one more equal sign to say that this is all equal
to the sum of the last column; that's an important
geometric point. Okay so we have a mess here. So we
have this like huge system of equations, okay, and
so I need to make sort of a few observations
about the system of equations but what I want to
try to you soon is that it's going to be really
difficult to try to solve this particular system
of equations with the extra requirements that all
these X's are different; and this is really sort
of the important the important bit.
- (I feel likeyou don't have to make that argument to me.)
(It already looks difficult but all right - more paper)
- Okay, soundsgood yes. We have nine variables, and we have these
six equations. And so I wanna I wanna think of
these nine variables as like a point in some
kind of space, and this space has to have room for
this many coordinates, okay. So I want this to be
a point it's it looks like this is going to be a
point in some kind of 9-dimensional space. You
know like usually we have like a 3-dimensional
space that has like X, Y, and Z coordinates - there's
only three coordinates - here I'm going to need a
space where I can write down 9 coordinates. Okay
so that looks like it could be a 9-dimensional
space, but there's something really special about
the equations that we have that allow me to cut
things down sort of by one dimension. Instead
of sort of- even though I'm going to write the my
points using 9 coordinates, they're really sort
of only 8 dimensions that are in the works.
In the same way that we talked about uh, you know,
some squares feel like you know they might be a
little fake; there's a sense in which some squares,
even though they appear different, they feel like
in our bones they're kind of the same okay. And
let me kind of show you that with something that's
probably a little more familiar which is sort of
the Pythagorean triangles. This is a very famous
triangle, the 3, 4, 5 triangle, and we have that 3
squared plus 4 squared is equal to 5 squared,
right this is the Pythagorean relation; but
you know here's a- it's a different triangle but
this is going to be a 6, 8, 10 triangle. And there's
something funny about this which is that, okay it's
still true, so 6 squared plus 8 squared is
equal to 10 squared - but somhow these triangles
don't really feel that different, it just feels
like I took this triangle and I just kind of
scaled it up. In a sense the- you know, the triangles
literally are different, but they don't feel like
a genuinely different triangle. It looks like it
just took the triangle I already knew and I scaled
it up. And the same thing is going to happen with
things like magic squares; it doesn't even have to
be magic squares of squares right? There's the
Lo Shu and so I can just take the Lo Shu and just
multiply everything by 2. So I'm going to put a
16 here, and a 2 there, and a 12 there, and a 6, and
a 10, and a 14, and an 8, and then 18, and a 4,
okay. And now everything adds up to 30 this time;
but that's not very surprising, I I just scaled
every single number by 2 and so you know the
equations that give you a magic square, you know
it's just like multiplying those equations by 2
and so this doesn't really feel like a genuinely
different magic square from the Lo Shu. In in a
literal sense it is different but somehow it came
from the same mold. And so so that's really the
important thing, is that that when we look at all
of these coordinates and I multiply them by 7,
when I look at my magic square of squares each one
of these entries will get multiplied by 49 because
7 squared is 49, and so every single entry will get
multiplied by 49 and then it'll still be true that
the rows and the columns on the two diagonals will
add up to the same. Any solution to this problem
and I scale it up or down I could also just have
fractions instead in there, I'll still have
a magic square of squares. So these solutions
have this very nice scaling property. And what
that means is that even though you see sort of
nine coordinates you only really have about eight
degrees of freedom. So the reason that's important
is that- so the natural habitat for these equations
is something like an 8-dimensional space.
What do I mean by the habitat of an equation?
So let me just remind you, you know, if I if I
just worked in the usual plane where I had X and
Y coordinates, so I had two coordinates I have two
dimensions, you know I can look at an equation like
this x squared plus y squared equals 1. This
is one equation in this 2-dimensional space
and it cuts out for us a circle of radius 1,
x squared plus y squared equals 1. And so what
we're doing here is something similar, it's just
much harder to visualize because I'm going to work
in a space that technically has nine coordinates
but only really eight degrees of freedom;
and inside that space I'm going to look at
the solutions of some big set of polynomials and
this set of polynomials will carve out a geometric
shape just like x squared plus y squared equals
1 carves out a geometric shape on the plane. It's
just that it's you know it's hard to visualize
8-dimensional space. So I don't know how to
draw that here, but but the object is out thereand it exists.
- (So not only is that impossible to)
(imagine the playing field, you also don't even
know what the configuration of the players are)
Right, that's right yes, yes. So so we really
have to sort of use use our imagination and
the algebra; this is sort of a really important
idea that that we're we're sort of trying to do
some geometry but but when we can't visualize
things sometimes the algebra is still there
and we can work with the algebra instead of the
geometry. So we have this 8-dimensional space
um and if you look back at the set of of
equations that we wrote, there are six equal signs.
And so each one of these equal times is putting a
constraint on this 8-dimensional space. So you
start with this 8-dimensional space and then I
put a constraint in it and so now what I'm holding
is probably a 7-dimensional thing. And then I
put another constraint in it and so now these two
constraints have to be satisfied simultaneously
and so the intersection is probably something
that's 6-dimensional. And I keep doing this, and
if I have six constraints well okay I'm just, you
know, right 8 minus 6 is equal to 2. Once
I sort of put all these constraints together
it looks like what I should have is some kind of
surface, some kind of kind of 2-dimensional thing.
Each constraint is sort of cutting me down in one
dimension; I started with eight degrees of freedom
and I've taken away six. And so um even though
it's very hard to actually visualize something
like this it looks like it could be some kind ofsurface.
- (So there's some 2-dimensional surface)
(that would hold the key to everything?)
- Exactlythis is exactly the point. There is out there
there is this sort of incredible - you know now
I'll just do like a metaphor for it - there's this
2-dimensional surface and each point on that
surface is going to have coordinates X1, X2, all
the way to X9, and this point encodes one of these
magic squares of squares. Now what's important-
(Has this surface got a name?)
- Uh no
- (Can I suggest one?)
- What would you like to call it?
- (The Parker surface)
That's awesome. All right, okay, let's call it the
Parker surface. Yeah so so any point on the Parker
surface is going to give you a magic square
of squares. Now this surface really is there,
I think one of the the things we have to realize
is that that these X's could also be like not just
integers. Right we are looking for integers, we want
integers, but but you know if I just sort of write
out these equations and I let X1 through X9 you
know be more general numbers - mean like pi or e or
you know some something with an infinite decimal
expansion that's random - um those are perfectly
good numbers too. And so what happens is that this
square is there but almost every time you write
one of these points down on it there's at least
one coordinate that's just not going to be an
integer or a fraction. And so so what we're really
trying to do is- you know our job is to try to find
a point on the surface all of whose coordinates
are integers and distinct, okay. And this is this
is where things get tricky, because inside this
space right you can actually take something that
looks kind of like a plane and then it'll sort of
cut the surface and this will be, for example, the
locus where like maybe two of the coordinates are
the same. That could definitely happen and you know
things like the Parker Square, you know, have the
property that some of of the entries are the same
and so for example it can be a point that happens
to lie there. And this is the tragedy that we seem
to face is that on this surface every time we have
a point that seems to give us a magic square of
squares these points tend to lie on these very
special curves of the surface uh where you have
conditions like you know X1 is equal to X2 or
X3 is equal to minus X7 or something like this.
(Because when you first told me about the surface I
thought maybe there'd be no points on the surface)
(where all all of them are integers; but there are
some there so-)
- That's exactly right and and this
you you hit on something really important Brady
which is that this is what makes this problem
really difficult is that that this surface really
has points with integer coordinates; it's just that
we don't like the points that we see. There's also
the one where you've set everything equal, just put
everything equal to 1, that's a perfectly good
point on the surface. 3 is equal to 3 is equal
to 3 is equal to 3 is equal to 3
is equal to 3 is equal to 3. That'llwork.
(This surface is obviously of infinite size?)
- Oh yeah yeah yeah there's there's lots and lots
of points on on the surface. So then this is what
makes it hard, so so in in there's this area of
math called diophantine geometry that that tries
to exactly solve this kind of problem where you
take a collection of polynomial equations like
the ones that define the magic square of squares
and and they try to find integer solutions uh - or
prove that there are no integer solutions other
than sort of you know a few obvious ones that we
see but that we're not really interested in. The
same thing happens with Fermat's last theorem which
is really aggravating. You know, Fermat's last theorem
has solutions right? You know 0 to the n plus 1
to the n equals 1 to the n. So the Fermat equation
has solutions; what makes it really difficult is
to show that there are no solutions other than
you know the solutions that contain at least one
0, okay. And that's uh that that's a much more
difficult problem; in math we have all these you
know a whole slew of techniques for showing that
systems of equations have no integer solutions
whatsoever but that's not the case here. There
are integer solutions, so what we're trying to
do is to show that there aren't solutions other
than the ones that we actually see and that's
a much more difficult problem to solve.
- (You told)
(me earlier that you've come to the conclusion that
it's really unlikely that one of these exists. What)
(you have shown me so far has made me more hopeful
that one exists.)
- Yes I understand; so so why why do
I think that one might not exist? Okay yeah- I I
guess I need another sheet of paper.
- (More paper. Take away my hope!)
Okay so I'm gonna try to explain why I think
that even though we have this huge surface worth
of points, all of which actually give you a magic
square of squares, there's just no point where all
of the entries are integers and they're distinct.
Why do these points even exist in the first place?
And and so this is a philosophical point but it's-
you know, points that satisfy polynomial equations
that that are you know all integers are very very
rare, they're sort of almost accidents of nature.
And and this is sort of something really important
to bear in mind. So we know if instead of a surface
if we had a curve, curves come in sort of three
flavors from the sort of integer arithmetic
point of view. The first one is called rational and
in fact the circle that we were looking at before,
this is kind of a perfect example of a rational
curve. What makes these curves themselves have lots
and lots of points that have either rational or
integer coordinates. You know, here's here's already
a point in on the surface (0,1), if I sort of
take the line that connects that point to some
number t on the real number line then I can do a
little bit of analytic geometry and compute this
thing. You'll see that it's 2t squared divided
by t squared plus one and then t squared minus
1 over t squared plus 1. This actually has to
do with Pythagorean triples but that's a story
for a different day. What's important here you see
is that if t is like an integer or some rational
number then these expressions are also going to
be integers or fractions more generally. There's
heaps of rational numbers on the real line and
so I just picked some rational number t and I do
this construction and it gives me a point on my
curve that has a rational coordinate. So rational
curves have this like incredible property that
the moment you have one point, okay I need I need
one point to get started, then I can use that
one point to construct lots and lots and lots
of other points. Then there's elliptic curves; so
elliptic curves sort of have this funny kind of
shape usually, they're defined by cubic polynomials.
Elliptic curves have this incredible thing that
you can add points on them, okay, so if I take Q and
Q - okay this is not P plus Q but if I just sort of
reflect it down - I can call this P plus Q and this
sort of crazy little construction that I just did
happens to actually sort of satisfy things like
associativity which is something that, you know,
if I have three things you know I can move the
parentheses around. So elliptic curves have this
crazy property that you can add points on them. And
the reason that's important is because it allows
you to also create new points out of old points; so
if I have an old point I can add it to itself for
example and then create a new point and then I can
add that point to itself and create a new point.
And so so elliptic curves have this also this
property that that if I start with a point I can
propagate it. So rational curves are great, elliptic
curves are great, in that you know you they can
come with lots of points. And then there's General
type curves and those those are sort of- well
they're sort of more complicated but one thing
that's amazing is that they always have finitely
many points with coordinates that are rational.
This this is a spectacular theorem from the early
80s, maybe 1982, it was proved by Faltings. And
he he got the Fields medal for this theorem so this
this was sort of a big a big deal, it was called
the Mordell conjecture back then and now it's
Falting's theorem. What we have is not a curve,
okay, it is it is a surface but I'm telling you
this story because it actually plays a very key
role in in our surface. So so when we have curves
they sort of come in three different flavors, two
of those flavors have lots and lots of points and
one flavor does not. So what happens with with
the surface that we were calling the the Parker
surface, right, is that as a consequence of some
work that me and a couple of co-authors, Nils Bruin
and Jordan Thomas, were working on is we managed
to show that on this surface right here there are
only finitely many curves of these two types. And
this is this is really something that surprisedus.
(So a surface is full of curves? Made of curves?)
- Exactly, exactly you can you can take a surface and
just like chop it up into lots of curves. And
then you know if you're looking for points on-
that give you a magic square of squares, one thing
you might try to do is instead of looking at the
whole surface just look at a curve inside that
surface. And maybe you get lucky and maybe your
curve is one of these two types and then you can
use what we know about these two types to actually
construct magic squares of squares. But the sad
thing is that the surface that parametrizes magic
squares of squares, the Parker surface, has only
finitely many of these rational or elliptic curves.
(It doesn't only need one?)
- It only needs one, you're
right, but but here's the the crazy thing is
it has more than one; in fact this uh this Parker
surface has 368 of these curves that that we know
of. So there's at least 368 of these rational or
elliptic curves. The sad thing though is that the
way we've constructed these is that we we looked
at slices like this, you know what happens if I
take X1 equal to X2 that gives me some kind of
curve on the surface? And then either this curve
or you know the curve itself might break into a
few pieces when I do the slicing. You know, those
individual curves are either rational or elliptic
but they have this property that X1 is equal to X2
so so the 368 curves that we can find, they
contain points but all of the points on these
curves are are going to give us these kind of
fake magic squares which is really really sad.
Umm okay and so here's the final kicker though:
there is a conjecture um so so Parker surface, so
this has finitely many finitely many rational and
elliptic curves. So so our idea to try to use these
curves to produce points uh it isn't looking so
good. Like I say this is, you know, some theorem that
came out of of work that that uh me and a couple
of of co-authors were uh working on. And I mean it
was kind of neat, I mean we didn't expect that that
we would be able to prove something about this
very specific surface. But now the kicker is that
there's there's something called the the Lang-Vojta
conjecture - this is the the incredible thing.
The surface that we have here is a particular
kind of surface, it's also called the general type
surface, and Lang and Vojta sort of made a series
of very deep conjectures, but when you apply those
conjectures to the surface what it says is that
outside of the rational and the elliptic curves
there can be at most finitely many points on this
on the surface, who all of whose coordinates
are integers, right. There's tons and tons of
points on the surface but there's only going to
be finitely many points uh out- outside of of the
this nice locus of rational elliptic curves all
of whose uh coordinates are going to be integers.
There's finitely many- I'll call them rational
points - outside the rational and elliptic curves.
So where does that leave us?
- (I get the feeling from
talking to you, as soon as a search space becomes)
(finite you become very despondent and lose hope.)
- Yes. It's finite because of this sort of general
conjecture but often finite can mean empty as
well. And so so it's entirely possible that it's
not not just finite it's just isn't there, there
just isn't a set of of points. So somehow the
moral of the story is that either we need to find
some more of these rational or elliptic curves on
the surface, and hope for the best. There's only
a finite supply of them so we're not- you know we
can't just keep trying this all the time; and
and in fact you know we might actually get a
complete list at some point of all of these and
then- you know, we really understand rational- you
know points on rational and elliptic curves, so once
we have that finite list- final list we'll be
able to ascertain whether you know you get one of
these magic squares of squares - at least sort of
from that point of view. Or the other hope is that
well, you know, we do this and we find nothing but
somehow there's this miracle and and for some
reason that we just don't understand there's a
couple, you know, one or of a few more sporadic
points on the surface all of whose coordinates
are integers. But but everything we know about the
geometry of surfaces and the geometry of curves
is really pointing to the idea that there just
isn't a 3x3 magic square of squares
in the way that we would like it with distinct
integer coordinates which is kind of sad. But I
want to end on a good note though, so okay I need
one more piece of paper. So what I want to
show you is something that's kind of mind-boggling.
So we've been asking for magic squares of squares
which were 3x3 grids that had this
property that the the columns, the rows, and the
two diagonals added up to the same thing and all
the entries were squares. Okay, but now you can do-
we can go for broke here-
- (Got a 4x4 now?)
- You got a 4x4 now, and this is kind of
amazing. Okay so this is a 4x4 magic square
of squares. This is not a fake magic square
of squares, this is this is the real deal. Due to
Euler around 1770, thereabouts. These magic squares
of squares have a very long history; if you look
here sort of all the rows, all the columns, and the
two diagonals add to the same number 8515. So this
is kind of crazy, you know there's a 4x4
but there isn't a 3x3. Okay. And if you
go on the internet you'll also find a 5x5;
and a genuine one not a fake one, you know like
we- and if you dig for it, you know there's also a
6x6 and so on. From the geometry point of
view this is actually not too surprising; in fact
I would actually think it'd be really cool
to show that that if you take an nxn grid
then - and n is at least 4 - then you can
produce one of these magic squares of squares.
And so-
- (What happened when you kicked up- Because I
thought if you applied- when you- I thought if you)
(applied that same process you just showed me
to this you'd have the same problem. You'd come up)
(with a surface that was really constrained)
- Exactly, okay so what happened, right? So so let me just sort
of explain briefly that right. So if I have like
an nxn grid right, that means that I'm going to
have something like what we did before. So this is
n entries this way and n entries that way okay?
So if you have an nxn grid you have n rows,
you have n columns, and you still only have two
diagonals okay; but now okay how many variables
do you have? Well there's n times n so there's
n squared variables. So in the 3x3
case there were nine variables; in the 4x4
case there were sort of 16 entries. So if
if you work on an nxn grid there's going to
be n squared variables. Okay so what- what has
happened here is that the the space in which
we're working in, right, the number of coordinates
that we're going to need is growing really fast
but but the number of conditions that we're trying
to impose on that space is not growing anywhere
near as fast as as the space itself. So the space
itself has dimension n squared - 1. And then
I have 2n + 2 things that I need to set equalto each other.
- (So the Parker surface is no longer)
(2-dimensional?)
- Exactly, it's no longer2-dimensional.
- (It's like a huge blob)
Exactly, it's like a huge blob right? Right we go up one
dimension to n equals uh 4 right, and now we're
in 15 dimensions. We've made roughly 8 cuts and
so it's like a big blob, it's not a surface anymore.
(Parker blob)
- Yes that's right, the Parker blob in n dimensions.
And so the cool thing though is that these sort
of conjectures that we have about points on these
blobs, right, it's not a surface anymore it's a much
bigger blob. And so things get harder and harder
as these dimensions go up but but the the the main
point is that the the geometry of these spaces as
the as n grows it actually becomes more positively
curved which means that it can barbor tons and
tons of these kinds of rational and elliptic
curves. And so so in fact um for for blobs of this
kind as n grows we actually suspect there are
lots and lots of points on those blobs. And so
it's sort of not too surprising from the point
of view of geometry that you would find a
4x4 magic square of squares. Or a 5x5,
or a 6x6, you know. In fact it'd be really
cool to prove that you can get an nxn for n at
least 4.
- (Now do you know what would be cooler? It's
finding some number out there, nxn squared, where)
(there isn't a solution again)
- Oh my God that wouldbe amazing!
- (By some freak occurrence)
- Yes that's right - and that
could happen, because you know in fact these spaces
are very singular and so sort of the the notions
that we have about what ought to happen may or
may not work in those spaces. I mean we sort of
think that probably it's going to be okay, but we
don't really know. And and no one has really sort
of sat down to explore these these spaces. There's
there's some really interesting mathematics; you
know at first it you know might seem like oh we're
just having some fun with with squares but there's
some really deep geometry that's that's going
on uh behind the scenes. And in fact I I can't
resist saying this but but this square that
Euler uh came up with is is really important
in the proof that every integer is a sum of- every
natural number is a sum of four squares. There's
a very famous theorem of Lagrange. In fact Euler
sent this particular square to Lagrange with no
explanation about how he had constructed it, you
know, and then Lagrange had to kind of work hard
and then you know Euler eventually did publish
the method and then once Lagrange saw what Euler
was doing you know he was really able to complete
his proof. But it's it's amazing to me that sort of
this that might seem just like pure fun actually
ends up having some some really sort of deep
and interesting consequences.
- (If you find allthe finite curves on there, the rational and)
(elliptic yeah and they don't throw up what
you need, can you prove that there are those-)
(can you prove that there are none of those other
points floating out there? Is that provable? Can)
(you say, yeah there aren't any points as well or
are they always going to be a bit of an unknown?)
I- with with current mathematical technology I
I would not know how to do that. And and I think
that that sort of- in general it would be great
to have some kind of mechanism to do exactly
what you just asked. You know can- once I remove
the rational and elliptic curves, you know can I find
this sort of hypothetical set of finite points?
- (Parker points?)
- The Parker points if you want yes.
Now look I know what you're thinking,
what does Matt Parker himself think
about all this? Well wonder no more, we have
a very special Matt Parker reacts video on
Numberphile2. There's a link on the
screen and in the video description.